there's always an issue happening right
now in today's headlines that links back
to the histories we work on at the GLC
so what I like to say to people is what
are you interested in what's the problem
you want to solve out there we might
know some history that can help you get
there I'm currently wrapped up in a
project president salv asked me to uh
direct and manage and write and that is
the history of Yale University with
slavery and
abolition Yale as everyone knows is
about 320 years old now uh it's a very
long
history uh and uh I have led a a team a
small team of both faculty and students
and Librarians who have been crucial to
this to uh
research uh Yale's entanglements with
the problem of slavery over time and we
made a decision very early in this
project not to write a
report per se which is what most
universities have done but to write a
real narrative
history at the GLC we have managed and
organized a whole array of webinars
panels
events for the Yale project over the
past two years we we've done panels with
uh the descendants of some of the
earliest black Yale students we've done
done panels with uh local New Haven
Community leaders we did a panel with
undergraduates to know what they thought
uh we've done U panels on the history of
eugenics at Yale uh
so by managing that project it gave us
another whole set of issues to to do all
kinds of Outreach about and because
that's what we're here for we're a
center for the study of slavery and
abolition but it's it's it's remarkable
sometimes how infinite it
feels uh when you start thinking about
all the issues that connect to us that
connect to the to the questions at the
core of our mission how can we work on
this aspect of social justice how might
we work on that aspect of repairing the
past to the extent we can how might we
work on that policy question but doing
more history beneath it um how should
universities look at their own past and
the past around them that they helped
[Music]
create